when they first connect and you see it i
thought that was really cool did you buy
into the neo trinity were did you buy
that love did you buy that plot well i
don't know about you guys but when i
talk about the matrix over the years
with people that have or haven't seen it
the first thing i talk about with the
original trilogy is man the love story
between neo and trinity is just so good
that's why i watch the matrix for the
love story fair point
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of the rt after show that's the
ron tomatoes after show and i'm your
host jacqueline i am not jacqueline
cawley i'm actually mark ellis filling
in for jacqueline who has a very busy
schedule she's probably covering some
really cool awards show or she's
hobnobbing with celebrities and i am
here and i could not be more thrilled to
be talking about the matrix
resurrections
[Applause]
we're going to be doing a deep dive into
that film today so the spoiler warning
is in effect all of our burning
questions what did we get answered about
the movie what do we still want to know
will we get more matrices all of that
and more with two very special guests
that i just love having these two on the
show because this is my first time
hosting it and who better to go in than
with the best and the brightest that is
certainly the case with the birds and
the hood co-creator the one the only mr
winston a
marshall who we recently had on my
podcast with jaclyn rotten tomatoes is
wrong talking about the matrix and
joining him is going to be from adam
does movies adam hollinger check out his
youtube channel and he is here in person
winston and adam are both here they
might have some divergent thoughts about
the matrix resurrections it is the
fourth film in the franchise just about
18 years after we saw the matrix
revolutions we had reloaded before that
and obviously the first matrix way back
when we were so young in 1999. now the
first three films were directed by the
wachowskis this one is directed by lana
wichowski solo and the film would make
140 million dollars at the current point
that we're talking about it in the
theaters which sounds good sounds like a
hit except the movie cost about 190
million dollars was its reported budget
and currently on the tomato meter 62
fresh and that audience score 63 so
again we're fresh but we're barely fresh
are we going to get into rotten
territory should the movie get into
rotten territory all of that and a whole
lot of details about the movie coming up
here on the rt after show but before we
get to any of that adam i want to start
with you when you first heard that there
was going to be a new matrix film after
so much time had passed what was your
level of excitement apprehension where
were you just on the announcement of a
new matrix film
thanks mark for that glowing
introduction uh i was giddy giddy like a
schoolboy um
it's been a long time the matrix uh big
big movie big franchise for me growing
up i was the impressionable teenager
when that film came out so i was
running up the walls pretending to dodge
bullets with the friends in the hallway
having the teachers mad at me so this
was a huge deal i actually you know
called my buddies when we saw the
trailer uh the trailer was really well
done i thought that final shot with the
agent smith 2.0 saying after all this
time to go back to the matrix and
yeah i was ready to go in trepiditious
yes uh the the wachowskis don't have the
best track record post speed racer and
for some even speed racers a miss i love
that film
but uh i mean cloud atlas uh
jupiter what was that jupiter rising
jupiter ascending and the one yeah the
one where he's got cat eyes
horrible movies so yeah i was a little
scared but
overall i was all in
all right so winston i know that you
were a big fan of the matrix trilogy and
you actually enlightened myself to a lot
of what's actually going on with the
mythology on your appearance with rt is
wrong now on the rt after show when you
first saw that matrix resurrections
trailer what did it do for you did that
validate your excitement about the movie
or did you see it and say oh wait what
are we getting into here it was so well
done in that like i it was it was almost
confusing when we get into the movie
that they they had this uh original this
white rabbit song kind of in there and i
think that perfectly scored
what we were getting into and i was so
excited
watching that trailer uh about what was
going down and and
it left so many just mysteries that we
weren't sure of what we were gonna get
into and we we get that once we actually
get into the film which we'll talk about
in a moment but i came into this
you know
almost as geeked as i was for for uh the
other major blockbuster that came out
last month uh or in december of uh
spiderman no way home like i was like yo
this is gonna be the wild like sad
season is here baby let's go
like that's where my mind was at and and
i you know i can't wait to start talking
about this film yeah you wonder if that
web slinger had something to do with the
matrix lack of box office as it pertains
to spider-man no way homage i think is
now the fourth highest grossing film in
the states of all time so here's what
the critics consensus is and we have
this because we see the tomato meter and
then we arrive at a consensus of all of
the critics and it is as follows if it
lacks the originals bracingly original
craft the matrix resurrections revisits
the world of the franchise with wit a
timely perspective and heart now which
sucks to pose that with the audience
consensus the matrix resurrections fall
short compared to the original but
doesn't skimp on the action or cool
visual effects i think i'm right in that
audience ballpark with my feelings on
the movie because again i didn't come to
this as a hardcore matrix fan i saw the
original when i was a teenager as well
and i was blown away by it i went into
the summer in 99 thinking okay this is
phantom menace and then that cool little
blair witch movie and then the matrix
just completely
reinvigorated the action franchise for
me um the martial arts franchise the way
that we do wire work the way the special
effects were seen the bullet time so
much in that original matrix so now we
fast forward to the matrix resurrections
winston i'm going to start with you your
expectations of the film were they met
do you agree with that critic's
consensus that it's good but falls short
of the original where is winston
marshall on the matrix resurrections it
is it is good it does fall short of the
original but i think what you have to
keep in mind and that's i think the main
message of the film which i really
that's what i really loved about it i
think the biggest thing about the matrix
is it's not about what's on the surface
with the bullet time
and the you know the ships and all that
stuff it's really at the end of the day
about what the core message is and and
what you get from everything from the
bots to uh the sequels upon sequels and
the metaness of it all is just from the
simple standpoint that like in the 90s
it did feel like it was like the man you
know what i'm saying the man is there
the man trying to stop you that's what
the agents kind of represented that's
what the architect represented etc
whereas now
it is social media it is the internet it
is our phones
everything that's bombarding us on top
of regurgitating the same things over
and over again so the fact that very
tongue-in-cheek we talk about how this
is uh almost a reboot in of itself i
thought when you get to the core of what
this uh what the matrix has always been
about about
where we are as a society and what's
keeping us shackled i thought that this
did a very good job of doing that though
there are some things that could have
been tweaked because this thing got a
little convoluted from time to time but
overall the messaging was there for me
okay so barely fresh according to tomato
meter maybe a little more fresh
according to the genius that is winston
marshall adam ollinger again you were
excited to see this movie are you
agreeing with winston with the critics
or do you think that maybe this movie
shouldn't be fresh at all
well i don't want to do the thing the
movie uh claims that we're gonna do
which is debate over what the matrix was
about originally um they they very
they poke fun at us a lot us nerds about
spending hours pooling over it but
the thing is the matrix was a slick
action movie
it had the don davis soundtrack it had
some amazing music going on it had the
beautiful choreography it had some great
action set pieces some great actors with
agent smith one of the greatest villains
of all time
and on top of that it had all these
layered philosophical things so we don't
even have to argue about what the
original matrix trilogy was it was all
of that stuff
so a lot of defenders i've seen for this
new film are saying you didn't get what
the original was about it wasn't about
the kung fu and the leather and the
shades or the coolness it was about the
message well no it was about all of it
so if you butcher 90 of the execution
all you have left is this deep script
you failed
but worse this movie doesn't have a deep
script it's just remember the matrix we
remember it and we're being jaded and
cynical about it and we're making a
reboot because warner brothers has a gun
to our head and they even mention warner
brothers in the movie so
no if failure all around i can't believe
that rotten tomatoes scores even as high
as it is honestly wow hey sir what is
member berries then there is going to be
a lot of nostalgia but sometimes that
does help in a movie especially when
you're purposely being as meta as what
the matrix resurrections intended i mean
my my initial thought watching
especially the first quarter this movie
was was how funny it was because i
wasn't i wasn't expecting that wry sense
of humor that winking at the audience
sort of thing and it might wear its eyes
out winking at us but i was enjoying it
for what it was so let's get into some
of these characters before we talk about
our overall thoughts on what happens
with them down the road i want to start
with jessica henwick because
as bugs now this is a new character and
we meet her as she's watching a scene
that we're all too familiar with from
the first matrix what did we think
overall of bugs i'll start with you adam
did you like that new character and what
it brought to the table
[Laughter]
i think she was
probably the better of what we have for
new characters um i liked her look i
like that she seemed to be trying as an
actress in the role
um
the name
you know whatever bugs bunny warner
brothers owns the looney tunes so of
course you have the synergy there and
the tie-in bugs of course is also
you know a computer term and she points
that out i
i did have a hard time understanding her
at points i feel like she had a little
bit of a mumble to her voice um
but i didn't really care that much about
what she was saying anyways it's not
like a christopher nolan movie where you
want to rewind just so you can hear the
actors over the sound um so that i guess
is telling about the script once again
but overall
i dug her look i liked the character but
they did kind of present her as almost a
new lead and then they just treat her as
an afterthought in the second half of
the film so very underdeveloped
yeah it bugs his storyline winston how
do you feel about that from when we met
the character to how her character ends
up
so that that to me is one of the flaws
of the film uh you're introducing
essentially what could feel like the new
trinity you know what i'm saying that
you have this opportunity to bring in
this new generation a new female heroine
that she could have her own time to
shine
and
you know obviously trinity and morpheus
when they first get into the first
matrix there uses a conduit to bring in
neo and then they but they are still
able to stand on their own too you know
what i mean it does feel like once we
get the ball rolling on this film and i
guess spoiler alert where you know
you're watching this i'm assuming you've
seen the film
uh that we go back into neo and trinity
and what's going on with them and it's
not that we don't want that of course we
do but i want to fully complete the arc
with bugs within this film uh it felt
like when you're at the end of the first
matrix trinity's whole point was you
know the oracle told me i would fall in
love with the one so i need you to get
up i like you know i can do that i can't
do this by myself i need you to wake up
and then neo steps into what he needs to
step into right
that doesn't really bugs just serves
almost as like a a uh
a surge protector for trinity in order
to be unplugged from the matrix again i
don't know if i necessarily love that so
it's one of my flaws that they did i
didn't feel they completed bugs's arc uh
but jessica i thought did a wonderful
job i thought that the action sequences
that she was a part of were really
really cool um and you know i i i agree
i'm not a big fan of the name bugs it
feels like we're doing space jam a new
legacy all over again
yeah you have bugs and then what i did
appreciate about about that is that it
is more war to sink our teeth into with
this because you have some old favorites
that are played by new
performers and particularly i'm
referring to your morpheus and your
agent smith now morphy is now played by
yaya abdulmatin and then you had smith
played by jonathan groff who literally
can do mine hunter then he can also sing
in frozen so what what can't the guy do
can he pull off agent smith and can yaya
pull off morpheus winston what did you
make of those return to form
performances was it something new that
you wanted did it just feel not quite as
original as you desired i mean that's
the the beauty of essentially making
morpheus
and
smith i mean smith was already a program
uh but with morpheus the way you
designed it is the allowed for that
recasting it wouldn't have necessarily
made sense with neo and trinity just
because they are
uh you know obviously they are still
themselves um but in this case uh for
those that didn't know morpheus died uh
in a video game uh that was tied into it
because that was the thing that a lot of
people forget about the matrix as well
that it wasn't just the three films they
had obviously the animatrix you had a
couple different video games into the
matrix as well as the matrix online you
had comic tie-ins you had all the stuff
that were a part of this world so before
the mcu was a thing that was like the
hotness of like bringing in all these
different stuff so a lot of people were
like why wouldn't you just bring back
lawrence lawrence was dead that's why so
now that we have this i think yaya who
has proven his steez uh for the last few
years did a really good job uh trying to
take up that mantle as you know and and
give it its own unique take since it is
the embodiment of morpheus
but it is a different character
technically um
and then obviously jonathan you know you
that's that is big shoes to fill um
i personally liked it i can see why
people wouldn't but like you know
i could tell once we got into it i was
like oh that's that's king george from
hamilton he'll bring you the funniest
man like he will give you what you need
and i can't think of more of a more
menacing uh
pseudo villain anti-hero than like a
pretty boy with blue eyes that's like a
mist
like you know i feel like he brought the
energy with that so i was i was pretty
here for that cassidy yeah adam were you
i mean again you built up hugo weaving
as agent smith in the original three to
be as you said one of the greatest
villains in cinema history is big shoes
to phil for any actor do you think that
jonathan pulled that off do you think
that yaya pulled off morpheus okay
well good news fam uh hugo weaving was
in this film uh so was lawrence fish
lawrence fishburne they came back
because we had
a clip show episode of seinfeld's amount
of footage being shown throughout this
thing i mean i was expecting george and
elaine to come out with jerry on the
sofa and talk about episode 93 and then
they show the video clips
this movie is insane i just can't
believe this was made like intentionally
and warner brothers signed off on like
yeah let's let's throw about 15 minutes
of footage from the old movies i'm being
over the top but
this that footage is sprinkled
throughout the movie i i just can't
believe that that was greenlit
maybe they had like something in their
contract where hugo was like i can't do
this i don't want to come back and
lana's like i got you i'll find a way
for you to get paid somehow in this
movie and we'll just slip footage of you
in i mean that's how it works right mark
hey look i'll be honest with you all i'm
watching the movie and i'm watching at
home i got my subtitles on um i'm paying
attention everything it did feel like at
parts that episode of family guy where i
think brian and stewie go back and
revisit the very first episode of family
guy and they're watching the events play
out and so that's where my brain goes
when i'm seeing this because
it's not just the references to the
original adam it's
you're seeing scenes entire sequences
from the original play out so i'm
getting the sense from you that the meta
didn't work as a whole was that was
there any part about that
realization that we did make these and
now they're made into video games and
everybody loves the video games that
that thomas anderson created in the
matrix resurrections did any part of the
the metaness of this new movie work for
you
it's it's weird because the matrix out
of all the movie properties that have
been rebooted or you know soft rebooted
like jurassic world star wars etc
terminator
it was like set up for reboots right i
mean rebooting is part of the matrix
itself it's in the storyline so they
didn't even have to bring back neo or
trinity or morpheus we could have gone
with a whole new cast a whole new
storyline the original trilogy was
clearly done
i have no idea why we had to drag half
these people back and not not the other
half it's like the later seasons and
lost when they want to go back to the
island but they don't have half the
actors so they're like uh we can kind of
wing it and some of you can be on the
plane to go to the island it's okay
it'll work it's fine it just doesn't
make sense um the meta stuff
no it was just kind of annoying the new
agent smith didn't work at all for me
because again it's reminded me of what a
great performance hugo gave and how that
story was completed and then to bring
him back
with really no arc at all i don't know
what he's doing there
he doesn't really serve any purpose
yeah
was this was this more an excitement for
you at just revisiting this property or
did you actually find a lot of the the
new philosophy within this baked in
metanis to be rewarding as a fan
i
i won't lie when we talk about you know
again for those that are big fans of it
when the architect talks about it it's
like you were the 13th of these
anomalies etc etc and it was made very
clear by the analysts later that they
just revived this
anomaly
in neo in trinity uh because of whatever
power they were putting out et cetera et
cetera i i do agree that you kind of
could have moved on but i think the idea
was that if you didn't tie it
closer to what we already know that
people may not tune in and i know that
this was definitely a situation of
trying to visit a cash cow but there's
also some sentimental value there which
we'll talk about uh in a little bit uh
with lana but um
i honestly like like i enjoyed the meta
i agree the clips were way too much i
think if you want to do the moment where
neo is now kind of reawoken and they're
in the room and stuff's playing in the
background that would have been fine for
me if you want to have one random fever
dream where he's asleep and he's
reliving that life that would have been
fine with me i think i agree the clips
upon clips upon clips upon clips
i just that was too much that was
another one of the big flaws that i
think that they overdid it um i don't
have a problem with talking about the
meta of rebooting and the matrix and all
that i think that that was brilliant i
thought that was very tongue-in-cheek
but it felt like uh even though it
wasn't the best movie i don't know if
you all have seen top five when you get
all them comedians in a room just
talking trash
amazing absolutely amazing and that's to
me what that room of them like how do we
design this new game just making fun of
what the matrix was i thought that was
hilarious including the post-credits
scene about the cat tricks i mean come
on man
why is everybody obsessed with puppy and
cat videos because they're incredible so
why not poke fun at them so
yeah i mean if i had the regrettable
task of trying to explain what this
movie is about to save my mom then i i
would say look it's a lot of remember
the original film in the original
trilogy but then once we get into the
plot
we actually see that neo and trinity and
their affection for each other is being
exploited
for energy which is a simple enough way
i guess my issue winston is that it it
wasn't just that one fun scene where
they're all talking about the first
matrix as a video game and the flaws
with it it seemed like we got about 10
of those sequences before we even get
into the actual plot of the movie once
we get there did you find that plot
rewarding
um i did in the sense of
this i
i guess i'm going to tap into this a
little bit earlier than i was originally
um so so obviously uh lily decided not
to join the film lana did
part of what was going on there
obviously warner was like we want to
reboot the matrix we want to do this all
over again um
lana and lily lost both their parents
within like a couple months of each
other it was it was something that it
really made a couple weeks it was
something insane um
this for lana actually said in a number
of different interviews
was
a
love letter um was a way to therapize
losing two of the most important people
in her life and what better way to do
that with two of the most important
characters that she's ever developed and
that's what if you
watch in this insane connection between
neo and trinity and about that love and
about that nothing will ever keep us
apart not even a whole different world
it almost felt like the two of them
maybe had gotten into different parts of
the afterlife and it was them still
finding each other it was things like
that
which i kind of sensed watching the
movie but then also hearing lana's
interviews about it and how this was of
like you know a send-off to her parents
i a thousand percent get what's going on
here and obviously it's gonna do
different things for different people
but like
after everything we've been going
through the last couple of years the
folks that and friends and family that
i've you know lost because of the
pandemic and stuff this resonated in
that regard of just like you know what
no matter what the world looks like that
connection is always going to be there
with the ones that you love and that's
what really kept me there despite the
things that were trying to distract me
from what lana was trying to say you
know adam winston just contextualized
that in a way that i hadn't thought
about when you look at this new film in
the sense of being a pandemic or coming
out of a pandemic because we all sort of
were in our own red tubs of goo for the
better part of the last couple years but
then there's also striking points in
this movie that did appeal to me
emotionally one of which is when we're
in the coffee shop and neo and trinity
sort of shake hands and there's that
connection you're actually touching
another human being which again was kind
of a no-no for the last two years in
real life when they first connect and
you see it i thought that was really
cool did you buy into the neo trinity
where did you buy that love did you buy
that plot were neo and trinity sort of
more on par with what you wanted from
this movie
well i don't know about you guys but
when i talk about the matrix over the
years with people that have or haven't
seen it the first thing i talk about
with the original trilogy is man the
love story between neo and trinity is
just so good that's why i watch the
matrix for the love story fair point
listen i lost a parent at a young age so
but i didn't make a crappy movie to get
over it like that's just
that that sympathy card winston
i don't like what you did there with the
sympathy card i've also seen people take
the angle like completely opposite where
warner brothers forced her to make this
movie or she would lose the contract so
she made it as bad as she possibly could
so i'm not gonna go down the uh the
different roads i'm just gonna tell you
what i saw
as for the love story in this
like
that was the weakest part of the matrix
trilogy i mean i like neo and trinity as
characters but
they're not the most like energetic
couple right there's not a lot of sparks
they're they're banging in a cave when
there's a rave going on uh she's talking
endlessly why there's like four tons of
rebar sticking out of her and i just
wanted her to die at that point in the
third movie
it's not good it's not good and much
disrespect man although although i did
like winston i did like that they kind
of humpty dumpty them back together by
like using like they're pulling all the
the rebar out of her and like giving him
new eyes and stuff that was that was
pretty funny symbolism like a studio you
know taking these these corpses and once
again resurrecting them for audiences
there was a lot of
cynicism there i appreciated i just felt
bad i felt so bad for those cute little
robots that that rescued neo and then it
was like well we got to go back and get
trinity and just like you can feel the
robot just like wait dude really you
want me to go right back in there are
you kidding me do you know the fantastic
beasts robots you out dog are you
kidding me right now
i was getting a i was getting a max from
flight of the navigator five oh sure
yeah i was just thinking of the robot
twig on the shoulder and i was thinking
that stupid twig from
newt scamander's personal affairs well
we can go down the the conspiracy theory
hole of uh how did this movie actually
get made did they want to make this
movie was this you know whatever the
fallout was but one of the big reasons
why any studio would want this movie to
come out is because keanu reeves is just
experiencing such a huge we're still in
this new keanaissance that really began
an earnest with with john wick and how
successful that franchise has been and
so now we get to see him back in the
matrix adam did did did canner reeves
become neo again or did it feel like
somebody was just doing a caricature of
a popular role that they had played
decades ago
i mean i think we all
thought the same collective thing he's
just john wick in this movie he's got
the long hair he's you know
unshaven most of the time he didn't
strike me as neo he
i he was kind of off on this i thought i
thought keanu was just a little off and
i love the john wick movies and i love
keanu reeves so i it was a bummer to see
him kind of
not really in his groove but then again
hit this version of neo
um
you know he like was kind of neo but not
he was doing a lot of force pushing but
he didn't really remember his martial
arts until he did and then forgets it
again
it's just a sloppy affair all around i
don't really have much to say i mean
winston i do agree with adam that i'm
watching neo for a lot of this movie and
maybe it's just the simpleton in me
which i fully admit is most of me but
i'm watching it like that bar scene in
superman 2 when you know that that's
superman and you see superman get
bullied and you're like can you please
for the love of god to turn into
superman this is killing me and so then
neo has the force field which is cool
but then there are moments where maybe
he doesn't have his powers he does have
his powers are you able to sort of
explain away that or did you just feel
like this wasn't the neo that you paid
to see
[Music]
yeah that's not happening
here's i think what my problem was with
it above all else if we're talking about
this is i know they were they were
resurrected um but if you're talking
about the idea this is 60 years later
they're supposed to be older
if maybe what it is is like the more he
exerts himself
then maybe he starts to slip i would
have bought that but this idea that if
he's supposed to have truly been
reawakened as
an anomaly as the one
i need my dude to be able to do more
than just constantly just like you know
you know pain from naruto like force
push you know invisible woman whatever
you want to call it bro i
i didn't mind that power being something
that he's using more but not at the the
cost of he can't really do anything else
that that that i didn't quite love
because it it what it felt like i didn't
even get the john wick vibe maybe just
the look because clearly you know he was
shooting both movies so they probably
were like look man you ain't touching
the hair you ain't touching the beard
fine he did shave though didn't he
didn't he shave that one
yes yes but that was after wick was done
filming it yeah exactly i would assume
they shot all that post but sure uh i
think they i think everybody learned
their lesson from henry cavill's lip
injustice
yes
but but i but i i just
it was one of those things if you would
if you would address his age and that's
why he can't quite get it the way he
used to
i think i would have bought that but you
didn't really ever address it and i
didn't love that um
it was very off-putting uh to be honest
with you so were there fight scenes you
did respond to were there were there
sequences in the movie whether it's the
train scene was something else that
you're like oh that was an awesome that
that's up there with anything i've ever
seen in the matrix as far as a fight
the train scene the train scene was
amazing i actually really really enjoyed
that uh even though it was an abuse of
his force push powers i actually enjoyed
the the swarm uh on the motorcycle with
him in trinity and and just kind of that
whole sequence of like are they really
gonna be able to get away with this type
of scenarios i thought that was great
and then honestly getting the muravinji
and again just to have him scream about
not like he's gone full old man hobo
like i've got like
all everything wrong with me at the same
time
he was back in form
uh so those those sequences were pretty
good for me
biting your tongue
you liked when the mirror video came out
looking like robin williams from jumanji
and he had like the lost boys from
hook come out
bro he was where he had particles on his
face
it was no it was the best man oh my god
are we talking about is this like the
action segment because that was such a
letdown too i mean and i and i think
john wick i think again with john wick i
think the choreographers were doing that
film instead of the matrix which is why
there is no choreography in this at all
really
that that i agree with i agree with the
fact that i don't think the choreography
was as up to snuff as we have seen there
are some that clearly they were working
on like i think getting yaya's character
to whoop the hell out of neo to try and
wake him up i think that that
choreography for him was on where it did
seem like it wasn't as much for cat
maybe keanu was injured or something
from shooting john wick i i don't know
y'all were bringing up a really
interesting point where the the fiction
of the movie does meet the reality of
hollywood because winston for you it
must almost feel like those old cowboys
49ers in the 90s
teams that were winning super bowls
whichever team had dion sanders and
charles haley was going to win the super
bowl so it's almost like the matrix had
the great stunt coordinators and the
fight choreographers and all that stuff
and then they all went on to go do john
wick and now it's like well can we have
him back for the matrix maybe yes maybe
no so adam i will i will open the
floodgates your thoughts on the fight
scenes you saw in this movie as a whole
can i call out one thing before adam
goes you had to bring up the nighters
and the cowboys right now you had to do
this you knew you knew
go ahead adam
i told ed our our lovely producer ed i
told him i get one of those with you and
that was the one i played my card i'm
happy about it
cut them deep you cut them deep mark
yeah adam so the fight scenes um
were they as as good
as
anything that we saw on the matrix i
mean are there any redeeming values to
those battles that you saw in
resurrections
okay
there's like uh
what bugs had that hallway chase at the
beginning where the agents were like
five feet away from her and couldn't hit
her for some reason i don't
the the thing was just incredibly sloppy
all around there is there was it's not
so much just the choreography that's one
piece of it it's how it was filmed the
the shaky cam is something that wasn't
in the matrix movies before we had more
stock you know framed shots uh because
the choreography needed to be seen to be
appreciated uh we're also missing the
tension
the the agents have no
stoicness anymore no there's no fear
being exuded from their presence i
barely remembered them being in this
movie and the fact that there's no blood
no one's really scared or fearful from
these guys it's just nothing works or
adds up it feels like so disingenuous to
call this a matrix movie even
i can't think of a single fight scene
that actually stuck out outside of the
the chateau or whatever that was in the
middle of
the water which was again just a
recreation of a much better version from
the first film
uh the agent smith 2.0 fight with
neo down in like a subway style i don't
know why that subway is down there it
was weird how they got there but that
was also just messy with shaky cam and
no stakes
so no i don't i don't think any of it
was
good as far as like a regular action
movie and it was certainly terrible when
you put it next to the great
action from the first trilogy
as we come out of this movie winston it
does seem like this agent smith has a
different end game or overall motive
than hugo weaving's agent smith what did
you buy of this new version of agent
smith and how that character played
itself out
i think
because that was the one thing that
could be a little confusing but i
understand kind of what was happening is
it by reviving neo you
ended up reviving smith because smith
obviously got destroyed at the end of
that trilogy and all that kind of stuff
right so
by doing so they kept him close by but
again he didn't even know who he was
until things kind of go sideways in the
the building he picks up a gun and then
he starts screaming mr anderson because
that the shackle unlocks he remembers
who he is so the idea of
smith is like look i need to go out here
and run around and make a bajillion
knees and fully take over the system
again as long as i have my freedom at
this particular point and him kind of
nailing that home and that's why he's a
shaky
ally in this situation
at first he's like i'm gonna whoop you
you're behind and you're gonna you know
i'm gonna kill you just because if i at
least kill you they can't plug you back
in i don't get reshackled right
once he realizes oh if y'all actually
get out of here i can still do whatever
the hell i want i understand why that
alliance comes out of nowhere it it
makes logical sense i'm watching it
twice watching it the first time didn't
help because i had to watch it at home
when it was christmas and everybody's
like hey get the ham out the oven it's
going but get the ham out i'm like can
y'all shut up did you watch this with
your family running around
bro it was the worst i i i sat in the
living room i was watching it like uh
you know my girlfriend was taking a nap
so i'm like okay nobody's here i'm just
gonna watch this real quick everything's
fine and then everybody came back and
now people are screaming and talking
about noises like what's this
is that is that keanu reed this is john
wick no just just
go away please just go away how the film
was intended to be viewed
i'm trying to tell you how it was
attempted to be viewed right
it seemed like adam it seems like you
wish you had more people distracting you
from watching this movie i saw this
opening night at the theater with my
buddies like everybody was fully locked
in that was the problem
i needed to watch you while like my
mom's making a casserole in the oven and
kids are fighting on the couch next to
me
shut up shut up i can't encourage y'all
enough subtitles are
they are a blessing on streaming
services i feel like i'm sort of y'all's
analyst for just getting your feelings
out about this movie one way or the
other let's talk about the analysts in
the movie the the plan of neo in trinity
and neil patrick harris playing the
playing the role adam was it the right
casting choice for you as the characters
sort of motives unfold
i didn't mind the casting i like i like
nph i think most people do he's a he's a
lovable person the the problem is just
the story and and having this character
to begin with uh what they really are
kind of dismissive of the original
architect and the original oracle it's
like a sentence or two he throws out
um
which is a shame because
it almost
kind of negates what neo did at the end
of the third film you know sacrificing
himself uh to kind of make a peace
treaty between the the machines and the
humans allowing people to have their
minds freed when you're going to have
this new young architect come in and
kind of steamroll everything and humpty
dumpty him back to life again
you know it's just like every other soft
reboot i guess and people will say that
the people that love this film which is
weird that there's people that love this
film they will say that that was the
point is
it's it's it's like saying ha ha you
know we're another recall another remake
sequel and we know we are so that gives
us a pass
uh winston i won't just bullet pat i
won't russell westbrook bullet past this
to you and say well was that the case
but i will ask you do you feel like just
having maybe it was it was neil patrick
harris is the analyst maybe it was
something else in this movie do you feel
like it did take some of the uh punch
and the emotion out of how we wrap
things up with the matrix original
trilogy
i think yes and no i think i think that
at the very least i can i can
adam and i are on the same agreements
that you could have focused more on the
new new um as far as like you could have
done a whole new kind of story like you
know
obviously the the
uh
s swilogy what what do we call
the sequels for star wars has its
massive share that has a massive
you know amount of its own problems but
you really focused on the three new main
characters for if you if you include
kylo
you know what i'm saying so there's more
focus on the next generation with a lot
of the old influence versus here it felt
like it was a lot of focus on the old
generation with a little bit of the new
i would have preferred more of that but
i like neil patrick harris what he's
doing here i understand his plan because
again if we're taking this and applying
it to kind of the themes they're trying
to get at the idea with reboots on top
of that is you look a lot of these young
people that come into corporations that
come into these they'd be like hey y'all
did that but we about to do this better
like i think about how
like it reminds me of a bunch of these
crappy tick tock influencers that will
take dances and they were already a
dance before and they were a great dance
and you're like nah this one is better i
think that nod of like nah it's not
you're not smarter than the people that
came before you type scenario i think
that acknowledgement of that
is part of what i really enjoyed about
neil patrick harris's like comeuppance
that the analyst gets you know what i'm
saying he thinks he's smart he's like
you're really not dude you really really
aren't and so i actually kind of enjoyed
that element of him being so smug
thinking that he did something new
when really he's just repeating the same
mistakes of his predecessors i i did
appreciate that as one i thought the
casting was spot on and simply because
of my generation growing up we so trust
neil patrick harris i mean that's doogie
hauser
when he was 13 i would have trusted him
to give me a hernia operation so of
course i'm going to buy everything he's
saying in this movie and then that's
going to be
my fate is is if i put all of my trust
in this person and so that was a new
character i really responded to it was
nice seeing jada pinkett smith back i i
thought that that was kind of cool and
then we also have trinity who ends up
becoming an anomaly so we wrapped this
whole movie up and we're talking about
now her being the one
what does that do for the character just
as you think about it in your head going
forward winston trinity now the one how
does that
sit with you
it kind of felt like they at this point
now it's it's it's it's both of them
right that they they that whatever
connection she had with neo has unlock
has unlocked her own because they're
both flying on their own accord at the
end of the film so it looks like you
know neo i guess needed to do a little
bit more pt and eventually did that and
then you know um
trinity now has unlocked this i i like
the idea behind it and i and i
would be
remiss to think that like at a certain
point um
everyone will eventually obtain this
level i i think that was the same way
that smith was like i could you you're
everyone in no one type scenario it felt
the same thing i know a lot of people
hate the last jedi i really enjoyed the
kid like force pulling the broom in this
idea that the force really is for
everyone it kind of gave me a similar
vibe of like
this could continue to grow into
something where everybody can really
have their own control and free will
that that to me
sounds what was a cool little thing that
i personally liked
okay and adam i'm gonna guess that you
weren't a fan of trinity and becoming
the one or was that maybe delicious
icing on a cake you didn't really like
i mean whatever it i was so checked out
i was so checked out by the end
my buddy actually turned to me in the in
the theater
and we were predicting things about 15
minutes before they happened and i'm
like i guarantee you this stupid movie
ends with her flying at the camera and
he turned and right after said
with rage against the machine plane
girl song and boom it comes up female
rage song strong female lead flying at
the camera with neo
whatever i mean again they could have
just
it's so it's just exhausting at this
point they should have just done a new
movie and you could have had bugs be the
new you know if you want to do like a
strong female character go for it do a
new do a new movie
i'll be honest i thought that's where
they were going to go with this when the
movie opens but as we know the matrix
the storytelling does get a little
convoluted and you leave a trail of
breadcrumbs before watching any of the
matrix movies particularly resurrection
so here's what i want to do with you
fellas now because i want everybody to
get all their feelings out so i'm going
to ask you a question but then i want
you to take that and extrapolate it and
let
this is now your pillow to scream
whatever you want into but i'm going to
start with adam and i'm going to ask you
are we likely to see
a matrix 5 what do we do with the future
of the matrix
did this make money
uh not yet
then not yet we're not
as soon as it makes some money we'll see
a sequel but uh
i i don't
i like i seriously don't know if lana
truly did want to make the movie like
this to be bad on purpose as like a
screw you to warner or if this really
was a whole
you know like a love letter to the
parents sort of thing or maybe it was
both i don't know
i i don't i don't see this continuing
because i do think there is enough
negative uh criticism about it unlike
the last jedi that's star wars it's a
massive property they were going to
continue that no matter what but with
something like matrix which was already
18 years before the sequel came out
i just don't think enough people care
for another one even the people that
like this don't seem to have like loved
it enough for more maybe winston can
disagree with that i don't know no no no
i'm i'm right there with you in the
sense that like i said i enjoyed the
film there there is plenty for me to
sink my teeth into that that i've spoken
on that i enjoyed but there's a lot of
problems as we've both brought up
throughout
the biggest one i think from the
business standpoint and you said it it's
at this point they have not made their
money back and so that by itself
they're gonna look at this and go ugh
i've made a huge mistake and then
probably walk away from this i don't i
don't think we're gonna see you might
see it in other forms you might see more
video games you might see more comics
maybe they trudge up uh an hbo max show
if they think there's something
to get out of it
but for the most part the matrix as we
know it i think is genuinely done yeah
and regardless of the filmmaker motives
here you do have to maybe decide with
adam that that there was a there's a
very
evident
premise here that we were making this
movie to sort of end this matrix ride
and but we could have it rebooted in a
different way i mean there because it is
a known property and those things are so
valuable in hollywood so it might not
just be the matrix five and here's neo
and trinity back in their continued
adventures is there room in the matrix
war winston to have just let's
completely scrap all that stuff all
those characters and just start with
different players and different pills
and different mentors and different
enemies is there room to do that in the
matrix and would you want to see it
yes
but
i think the problem is this was your
opportunity to do that while you still
had people's attention i think you have
you know the this is the opposite of the
leo quote from django it's like first
you have my curiosity now you have my
attention now it's kind of like uh well
you had my attention you fully lost my
curiosity get off of my plantation or
i'm going to put you in shackles like
that's kind of what this feels like
right now is that i don't think
i don't think people are going to want
to nest unless you're you're talking
about the absolute die heart of the die
hard i don't think folks are coming back
to this
so adam you're you're disappointed by
this movie i'm guessing and
when you
take a look at your your fandom i mean
you love this property you were such a
fan of particularly it seems like the
first movie but you celebrate the the
the first trilogy of it
so
if this is me i'm looking at this movie
if i didn't like it like batman and
robin where okay
we just have to let this thing lie and
then hopefully we can reboot it down the
road just you as a fan of the matrix
take the business of it out take the
money aspect of it out you as a fan of
the matrix are you of the mindset now
where hey we just need to let this
wounded dog lie or no there is a better
way to do this and i hope we get to see
it
well i mean i always think there's
better ways to do pretty much everything
um especially with new cinema it seems
like they're not caring as much as they
used to maybe that's just my jaded
opinion but i look at something like the
fantastic beasts property i i gave the
first one a pass i thought it was like
this is a little messy but i love the
harry potter franchise so i'm willing to
keep going and then the second one just
completely let me down so that's another
case where maybe we just walk away from
this and start over again because
much like hogwarts and the whole magical
world the matrix is just rich with ideas
and with lore and new things to mine i
mean they had a couple video games and
they had the animatrix but man i
honestly can't believe they didn't do so
much more with this property over the
last two decades than they did i'm
honestly quite shocked they didn't i
mean this was a money making franchise
you know so yeah i think that you get
the right director involved you get a
vision there that's that's you know
cohesive with warner brothers or whoever
owns this property on the road
absolutely go for it make a matrix with
passion again give it that darker edge
that the first movie specifically had
but the later ones still had a bit of
you know give it some biting commentary
give it some layer get some damn
choreography and good action in some
revolutionary effects not this cheesy
shutter effect they were doing with
really poor color grading get don davis
back as a composer or someone with some
competent skill
and you got a great movie again so as
we're thinking about this franchise and
whether we like the outcome of this
franchise whether we didn't
you know you have those theater
experiences that are so rewarding for me
it might be a star wars it might be
something that i'd never heard of that i
walked in a movie i was like oh i don't
know what this is it could be the
refining of the love with something like
the batman begins but then
eventually every franchise has to say
goodbye before it wears its welcome out
so i'm gonna give each one of you
winston and adam a chance to talk to
another franchise that you don't want to
see go down the way of at least how adam
feels about the matrix so now you get to
prevent a franchise from just dipping
its toe in the water one more time and
maybe spoiling what we had loved
previously so adam i'm going to start
with you because again you're not a fan
of the matrix you wish that this movie
was a lot better what's the franchise
that you want to talk to right now and
say hey y'all you see what happened with
resurrections do not make that mistake
i don't know who owns this currently i
believe robert zemeckis has the rights
but back to the future the trilogy is
pretty much perfection
leave it
bury it
don't go find it don't dig it up i don't
want to see a scenario where
robert zemeckis is dead and gone and
paramount or whoever goes to his grave
and pulls it off like voldemort and
harry potter and grabs the rights to
back to the future raises it up to the
sky and then we cut to black that cannot
happen
don't touch back to the future
i think that is a great call and i do
like adam's suggestion that whoever
would be that producer that wants to
reboot back to the future let's call
them voldemort or just the one who shall
not be named because
they were i love the back to the futures
winston they were running them on one of
ted turner's cable network shows again
and i just i sat down i just watched the
entire trilogy that was my day because i
just loved those movies so much so i
co-signed adam's plea keep back to the
future as the standalone trilogy it
already is what does winston marshall
want to put the brakes on and say hey
franchise don't make the same mistake
potentially that some fans feel like
resurrections did yeah and the problem
is they've already just done that with
so many of my films man ninja turtles
rush hour uh you know like all just
stuff all over the place so i'm gonna go
with one based off of a trend since we
saw hbo
do a
a light remix of you know a prequel in
the many states in newark and you have
and then and uh and whatever the the sex
in the city and then and then this
happened or whatever whatever that
nonsense is if you touch the wire
we gonna have to exchange hands
leave the wire alone don't make no movie
don't make no reboot just let it lie
you
are telling me if you saw a trailer for
a new market
because i know people enjoyed many
saints
not everybody but indeed some people did
i've heard nothing but nonsense i don't
even watch sex in the city but i've
heard nothing but people just just
crapping on that
it's a classic
let it stay a classic if you want to put
it in 4k fine but you leave the wire
alone
leave it alone
all right leave the wire alone and leave
back to the future alone but if you are
going to get a door and go back in time
one more time i think i speak for adam
ollinger maybe take that to warren and
go back and say hey maybe let's not
touch the matrix after all and leave
that as a person
and so i want to thank my two incredible
panelists here today i learned a lot
about the matrix i
still have my mixed feelings about the
movie as most fans probably will leaving
this and that's what the fun of this is
is that you get to rectify this with
your own thoughts and we had two experts
on here today to give us their take uh
adam allenger where can everybody out
there find you i know you have a
thriving youtube channel and you're
doing well doing what you love talking
about movies where can all the folks
find you
oh just right on youtube at adam does
movies
i'm on twitter at the same handle but
the the youtube channel is pretty much
all you need you just you have that
healthy distant relationship between you
and the blue bird
you tune in when you need to and when
you don't i'm gonna go on social media
if i want to be depressed i'll go on
twitter and yeah
don't go on twitter because you don't
know what's going to happen winston i
was watching you and your
your cohort is also a friend of the show
jay washington on boards in the hood it
looks like you all had a lot of food
items on your table do you want to
enlighten us as to what exactly was
going on yeah so uh you can find me
everywhere that swaggy birds are sold uh
twitter instagram facebook all that good
stuff uh youtube but as as mark was
mentioning we i do a show with jay
washington called blurbs in the hood uh
we had happened to hit a donation goal
uh where we attempted the hot ones
challenge and
uh for me being west indian you know i
had my moments where i was like this
pretty hot but i was doing fine jay on
the other hand if he even like sniffs
like medium hot sauce from taco bell has
a full meltdown so watching him do the
bomb and the last dab was one of the
funniest things i've ever seen
um so definitely check that out
youtube.com slash blurbs in the hood
that's b l e r p s the letter n t h e h
double o d so come check us out you can
watch either on youtube or on twitch
twitch on tv slash words in the hood so
much love 2j for that i hope
well i hope you were able to uh you know
get out get out of the bathroom a little
bit my friend i was very concerned about
you
at the end of that at the end of that
challenge my friend that's a problem
with guys like jay washington they're in
the gym all day he's built like a brick
out house and then you got to put some
of that stuff in your body it just
doesn't drive and you think it used to
so that is adam allinger that is
wednesday marshall i am merely mark
ellis thank everybody for tuning in to
the rt after show today talking about
the matrix
we reloaded it and then we
revolutionized it and now we have
resurrected it and once again 62
is the tomato meter so it's still fresh
as of now 63 with that audience score
you can find us at rottentomatoes.com or
on social media at rotten tomatoes i am
at mark ellis live for all upcoming
stand-up shows i might be in your city
go to mark ellis dot live and for the
hard-working engineering team behind the
scenes including edric who said i could
make fun of winston's cowboys once
thank you for tuning in to rt after show
winston enjoy the off-season
[Music]
you got beat both times boo and one was
a shellackin i know it was it was brutal
it was brutal
[Music]
[Applause]
you